but the really more important thing i
would say is um if you remember october
access hollywood tape comes out right
yep at that point trump's candidacy was
not looking good it was two
yeah all the like a lot of mainstream
republicans were backing away the donor
class is like nowhere to be found and
and the two things happened one of which
is like wikileaks right and i think that
probably helped trump a lot more than uh
peter thiel but but i think teal coming
in making a you know 1 million plus
donation pretty big donation you know in
turn as far as these things go and
giving a speech where he kind of tried
to contextualize
you know put into context the remarks to
defend them essentially where he didn't
he didn't defend trump for saying you
know grab him by the [ __ ] but what he
said was hey you know
we ought to take this guy seriously yeah
he has some he you know seriously not
literally that was that was the teal
catchphrase and i think um you know that
was that had some influence and it and
in terms of both like changing the news
cycle
and i agree and so so i think i think
all that made like a a a significant
difference i don't know again i think
trump uh you know there were a lot of
things that went well for trump and and
i'm not sure
maybe maybe could have done it without
teal but it was a very close election so
um
it does seem like zuckerberg um
has been influenced by
peter thiel in an outsized way
peter obviously liquidated his facebook
shares he doesn't think facebook is the
most important company in the world he's
been pretty
clear about that yet
um
he still seems to have his ear and he
seems to have walked him into the white
house
and created a pretty
um
a chummy relationship and it does seem
like zuckerberg is taking a page this
very week maybe even yesterday when
we're taping this
over uh from trump's playbook which is
never apologize go on the offensive
attack the messenger which is what
they're doing with the facebook
whistleblower today so what do you think
the
impact teal had on zuckerberg is
obviously teal had a big impact on sean
parker a friend of mine um yeah who
obviously had a big impact on
uh zak do you think zuck is actually a
republican do you think he actually
voted for trump do you think he's more
aligned with trump than
say hillary i think that or joe um
okay so
i don't i think that zuck's politics are
pretty hard to parse i would guess that
you know um his politics seem to be uh
facebook uh it's like uh facebook is
his political view um share price but i
do think um
but i do think that peter has had a
really important influence on him i mean
i think the business influence is very
clear right like you can see the ways
and zuckerberg has talked about this the
ways in which kind of teal's um view of
building startups had an impact on
facebook and i think you see in the kind
of facebook like move fast break things
like that that spirit i think comes to
some extent from the paypal mafia and i
think you could even you're probably
gonna think this is a little crazy but i
think it's not like i think you can draw
a line by some of these from some of
these provocateurs that peter has been
around to zuckerberg i mean zuckerberg
in is in his own way not all that
different from like you know keith reboy
or something like he's he's like
sticking it in the eye of harvard
remember you know he was he was fighting
with harvard over this um you know
whatever the preacher basically yeah
yeah the facebook precursor and like
he's totally like another one of these
kind of like you know bad boys right
like and and i think i'm ceo [ __ ] as a
card 100 yeah so i think there's that
and i think um it's pretty clear that
okay so maybe not pretty clear it's like
clear as mud that he has somewhat has
some pretty libertarian views i mean
we've seen some of them come out and
basically in terms of the way he thinks
about um you know speech and like like
what is facebook's responsibility to
society i mean it seems like he
basically thinks that the answer is none
um or or something close to none um and
that it's important to to take that
position in order to maintain freedom or
or something something along those lines
like i think that is um probably has a
lot to do with peter's influence um
uh and um as you said i think that peter
played a really important role kind of
in the trump era with zuckerberg so
um
zuckerberg if you go back to 2016 right
he was getting hit really hard over this
like kind of mini this is like a really
stupid story but like it was a big deal
at the time the trending topics thing
yeah they had like created this little
sidebar
and like no one was even looking at it
right but like it but but it got spun up
into a big to-do in conservative media
um
and conservative media i think rightly
sends an opportunity here to like you
know
in kind of like the classic sort of
breitbart like let's let's let's try to
move the overton window kind of thing to
to sort of go after facebook and say
that they were um going you know
discriminating its conservatives and um
that became like politically very
salient um you know and and that would
have been really bad for mark zuckerberg
because donald trump as we know is like
not averse to like sort of meddling in
the business world to you know you know
to yeah he likes to shake just swing a
bat exactly
takes everything personal and you know
there are people in in trump's world who
are talking about some like very extreme
things um with respect to tech you know
peter helps arrange this kind of peace
summit in 2016 where he had like glenn
back and a bunch of other well-known
conservatives and they make peace the
you know zuckerberg says
yeah zuckerberg says
to me it's um you know it isn't the kind
of far right right it's like mainstream
you know like glenn beck is as far right
as i think maybe
a little wacky he i think maybe had been
shapiro there no um but no breitbart um
no breitbart no milo
right who's that weird character with
the beard you go into a bunch of details
with uh charles
no charles johnson charles johnson i
thought that was a very interesting part
of this we'll get to that in a second
but they do that summit they kind of
make peace and then they start showing
up on the
trending list and now they were on the
trending list too much
uh yeah yeah and so um there's this kind
of um there's this whatever there's this
kind of peace accord um where zuckerberg
kind of says hey you know i'm for free
speech and you have like glenn beck does
a you know post saying you know
facebook's okay man um and uh this is
remember glenn beck was like really
going for like reconciliation at that uh
during that during that time or
relevance uh yeah okay and um but but
but so it that i think that helped um
and i think there was and i think that
probably
influenced you know facebook's
reluctance in 2016 to really kind of
figure out what was going on on its
platform i mean you know there are lots
of other possible explanations and i
think you know with a company like
facebook it's a mistake to like see any
one you know what i mean it's probably
like three or four different things at
once but i think they had there there
was definitely political incentive to
like let stuff go on on that on the
platform and then i think you know going
into 2020 like i don't know who zuck
voted for but i think he was way more
afraid of the democrats than he was
afraid of trump because trump had been
very good to facebook for the most part
right facebook has been growing um yeah
like trump every now and then he gets on
twitter and says something obnoxious but
but um zuckerberg obviously has a good
friend uh and and board member who's in
the kind of in the inner circle
and um and trump hasn't really done
anything to face yeah that's that's
where taking trump seriously not
literally actually applies he could say
whatever he wants but what is he
actually doing to break up big tech the
only thing he really did was say we're
going to kick tick tock out you better
find a deal and that said in motion that
whole oracle microsoft
you know we gotta find a deal for tick
tock that actually was the only thing he
did against tech that had teeth
for so many leaders there's a moment in
your personal and professional life
where you realize you're in your own way
yes you're the blocker you know you need
help and that's exactly where belay
comes in but delegating your bookkeeping
to someone can be intimidating and scary
imagine though how your business would
transform if you didn't have to worry
about producing reports and balance
sheets if you had more time energy and
focus to work on things that only you
can do like your product or hiring you
could achieve bigger goals because you
have the freedom to focus on what
matters allay the incredible
organization revolutionizing
productivity with their virtual
assistant service for growing
organizations can help you
that's why they're giving our listeners
a free download of the cost of not doing
your bookkeeping your finances are not
the place to be experimenting holding
your breath fingers crossed and hoping
for the best so if you're ready to wave
the white flag on handling your red and
black margins let one of the lays
experience remote bookkeepers help get
back to doing what only you can do
growing your organization and leave the
bookkeeping to belay just text twist to
55123 or visit
belaysolutions.comtwist for your free
download of the cost of not doing your
bookkeeping today